my name is Santos aw have discussed some
samples of I'm such a retro print I mean
it's media and name cream radio so this
radiation of the Sun and through
incremental itches and thanks for all
journey to establishing but the climate
change I think media can take role in
reducing the climate change by
increasing awareness of people are about
this problem and I do that in my radius
so we have a program specially on Andrew
mental issues but my radio also
encourage people to take part and make a
better man of incremental yes for
example we have programs that we call
the three adoption program to increase
our listeners to take part in reputation
project the planet 3 and the National
Park namely guna be a piranha so they
can you need some money and then
planting tree there make the forest
better I think we're doing that we have
to reduce the effect of planet shapes